What is your opinion on taking CBD and THC oil?
So there is literally no downside to CBD.
I haven't even heard of it, but it has a sensitivity to CBD.
So there's no downside to CBD.
CBD can be, can act like a flavonoid as far as anti-inflammatory goes.
It can be good for the brain, it can be calming for the brain.
CBD has those benefits.
But CBD is not like a pain reliever, like I'm just going to take the CBD and my pain is
going to go away, similar to if I took a Tylenol or an adbil.
THC on the other hand is the psychotropic type of the cannabinoids, and that's what's going
to give you the high.
So THC has some negatives, it has some downsides, it's going to make you feel loopy.
THC in a low dose can be really good for just helping you sleep, helping with anxiety,
helping with stress.
If you're taking high dose in what you just said, Riximson oil or RSO, so that's the high
dose CBD, so it's boiled down, it's distilled down, so this pasted, it's like a, it comes in
a syringe, and it's a very tar-like, if you put it on your finger and you have to literally
scrape it off of your finger with your tooth, because it's that tarry-like, very high concentration,
and that is what is used for a quote-a-quote cancer killing protocol.
I'm very much a fan of it, very much a fan of it, if you can tolerate it, okay?
So I took RSO and a number of years ago when I was really doing really poorly, I was willing
to give it a try, holy cow, I've never smoked a cigarette or got drunk, I've been just
lived kind of a, kind of a clean life that way.
I really reacted to RSO, I took too much of it to begin with, that was the problem, and
it became a really funny story around the office.
But besides that, I don't want to get too deep into that.
I just, I had to go off for a while and I tried to go back on it, it just makes me really
loopy, I just don't feel good with it, so everybody's a little bit different.
So I would, if you're going to try that, I'd highly suggest trying it, don't try away
from it, but go slow, just go slow under your dose, now typically in RSO protocols you start
with one grade of rice three times a day, that's too much for, that would be way too much
for me, it might be too much for you.
I would say you would go start slower than that.